gérald darmanin dans une interview au
monde se saisit du dossier des étrangers
ayant commis des actes graves en france
notamment ceux arrivés sur le territoire
avant l'âge de 13 ans nous voulons
permettre l'expulsion de tout étranger
reconnu coupable d'un acte grave par la
justice une marée humaine à l'assaut du
palais présidentiel
les manifestants pénètrent à l'intérieur
ils réclament la démission du président
gotabaya rajapaksa qui vient de fuir le
palais à droite marine le pen déplore
une nouvelle promesse qui ne sera pas
tenue en publiant un extrait d'interview
du président de la république qui en
2010 est déjà promettait la même mesure
des habitants excédés par la crise
économique sans précédent qui frappe le
pays
la résidence du premier ministre à
également été attaqués et incendiés et
les français attend cela on connaît les
règles dans ce pays et sur les connais
pas il faut rappeler les règles c'est ce
que gérald darmanin ne cesse de faire et
quand on ne respecte pas les règles
c'est comme dans le sport monsieur haye
il ya des sanctions un des principal
défi que connaît notre système éducatif
c'est qu'il est sans doute l'un de ceux
qui reproduit le plus les inégalités
changement de slogans et de doctrine du
gouvernement qui a dévoilé son projet de
loi sur le pouvoir d'achat remet dans le
parisien ce matin à gabriella talent
évoque le passage du quoi qu'il en coûte
ô combien ça coûte on a aussi un
paradoxe d'avoir encore un taux de
chômage qui n'est pas celui du plein
emploi est néanmoins des entreprises qui
éprouvent des très grandes difficultés à
recruter donc ça veut dire que notre
système éducatif notre système de
formation manifestement ne forme pas les
compétences dont notre économie a besoin
c'est la plus forte hausse de pouvoir
d'achat sur un quinquennat depuis des
décennies dans notre pays qui veut bien
dire que c'est notre combat et que c'est
pour ça que nous baissons les impôts est
fait pour ça que nous intervenons en
soutien dernière fragile mais pardon
vous noterez en touche c'est important
le discours aussi que nous devons avoir
pour les français c'est que nous devons
faire attention aux dépenses publiques
ça ne sera pas le n'importe quoi qu'il
en coûte ajoute aurore bergé la patronne
des députés du camp de la majorité des
propos qui interviennent à la veille de
la présentation et l'examen de la motion
de censure demain 16 heures c'est encore
un numéro de claquettes qui est mis en
place par par la france soumise et
l'équipe de monsieur mélenchon mais vous
savez l'alliance de la carpe et du lapin
ça fonctionne pas se mêlant sont ils
fait d'aider des petits sauts de lapin
partout avec ses équipes il a tellement
bien réussi qui l'a endormi complètement
le ps les verts et le pc je suis apte à
lille et ancien porte parole du
gouvernement il est là pour habituer les
esprits à ce que les mesures des de
pouvoir d'achat qui ont été celles du
gouvernement s'arrête parce que c'est ça
ce qui va se passer
la frange elle et feast delà du ps qui
est prompte à nous faire le procès de
travailler ou d'accointances avec le rn
ce qui n'est pas le cas a fait adopter
cette semaine deux amendements contre
l'avis du gouvernement avec les bois du
rassemblement national
emmanuel macron il a acheté son élection
à à part le quoi qu'il en coûte dans les
dernières dans les derniers mois et
aujourd'hui dit maintenant que je suis
élu les enfants on va couper les
robinets vous avez été bien gentils
et vous vous êtes fait vous êtes fait
avoir elle est loyal elle adore cet état
elle sera une vraie guerrière pour les
tailles pour le pays sarah palin
me de répétition sur les champs-elysées
la garde républicaine régler les
derniers détails du défilé du 14 juillet
messieurs on a besoin que vous revenez
pour quatre ans de plus qu'à 30 plus
les 200 cavaliers se fraie un chemin
parmi les voitures et les noctambules
éberlués
c'est cool que j'ai jamais vu il est
temps qu est ce qu elles étant des fonds